hey guys as some of you know we have
just terminated our advertising contract
with surf shark yes we were made aware
that they stopped advertising with the
post-millennial because of some false
allegations about their editor and our
former guest andy noe as you know as a
team we have made clear our support for
free speech and we will never advertise
businesses that bow to the mob is just
not going to happen here one of the
problems with council culture is that if
we rely on a small number of advertisers
to generate the money we use to pay our
team and fund the show it's incredibly
easy to end up in a position where we're
forced to choose between sticking to our
principles and delivering the great
content that all of you enjoy we can't
be in that position
we can't we'll end up self-censoring not
interviewing certain people because
we're afraid of the consequences and
we'll end up shying away from the really
important conversations about difficult
subjects that we have here so we started
trigonometry three and a half years ago
with no help from anyone just two broke
comedians who thought someone had to
have honest conversations about subjects
the mainstream media ignores
the only reason this show works is that
it's funded by you our fans and
supporters if you want us to be able to
continue having these conversations
without constantly looking over our
shoulder this is your opportunity to
make that possible lots of you already
support us on patreon subscribe start
paypal and locals and we really
appreciate that thank you and please
keep it up and if you have yet to get
involved our locals community has just
over 600 paid supporters help us get to
a thousand by the end of the year you
can check locals out for free and when
you're ready it's just seven dollars a
month and at higher levels you can get
loads of cool rewards 25 bucks you get a
mug 50 bucks you get monthly calls with
us and other top supporters whilst at
200 bucks you get all of that and free
tickets to our live shows and we'll take
you out for a meal which is always my
favorite part use the link in the video
description and pin comment to join
locals we'll see you there